hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll you
may know from listening to mindscape in
general or my amas in particular or uh
reading any of my books there's
something out there called the
multiverse well what i should say is
there's an idea out there called the
multiverse we don't know for absolute
certainty whether or not there actually
is a multiverse out there
in fact there are different kinds of
multiverse which i would assign
different credences to taking seriously
there's a quantum mechanical kind of
multiverse which i take very seriously
there is a cosmological kind of
multiverse we're literally just very
very far away there's different pockets
of space-time where things behave
differently that i'm kind of indifferent
about you know maybe it's there maybe
it's not there's good reasons to take it
seriously but we honestly just don't
know there's also more philosophical
kinds of multiverse the philosopher
david lewis famously advocated modal
realism the belief that every possible
version of the universe is actually real
in some sense and the question of
figuring out which universe we live in
is just locating ourselves in the space
of all possible worlds you may also have
noticed that the idea of the multiverse
has moved beyond science and philosophy
to
narrative to movies tv shows books
things like that this is not a
completely new move uh fiction writers
have used the notion of a multiverse as
a device for decades now but it's
gaining popularity a little bit back
when we had uh scott derrickson as the
guest here on mindscape he had just come
off directing dr strange the marvel
movie the new sequel it will be doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
which follows up on the most recent
spider-man movie which also
investigated the multiverse idea so it's
out there okay we're using it there's a
new movie which i very much encourage
you to see called everything everywhere
all at once that just came out as i'm
speaking this in mid april 2022 uh and
it's by daniels daniels is the
collective name for a writing directing
team of daniel quan and daniel scheinert
and they've made this movie starring
michelle yo which has a multiverse
concept in it i'm not going to give away
too much don't worry about spoilers here
but they use the multiverse in a very
interesting way because look as i know
from talking about the many worlds of
quantum mechanic which is one version of
the multiverse you can talk about the
schrodinger equation and decoherence all
you want what people really latch onto
is the possibility that there are other
versions of yourself
out there real people who are
experiencing
slightly different or very different
realities in some way it is undeniable
that that's a concept that grabs us that
really makes us think about this some
people contemplate it and reject it as
terrible and dumb and ontologically
extravagant others are sort of charmed
by the romance of it all some of us just
stick with the equations and try to make
sense of them as a physical theory but
all of us are thinking about these ideas
so in everything everywhere all at once
the idea is that evelyn who is played by
michelle yeo a very famous wonderful
just about ideal actor for this role
uh starts out kind of
in not in trouble well i guess in
trouble is okay but anyway her life is
not going great okay
there's family issues there are issues
of paying the taxes on her laundromat
that she and her husband owned uh
there's just issues of putting food on
the table and so forth and honestly
owning a laundromat isn't that
sexy or exciting so it's it's a kind of
life that is a little bit gloomy and
struggling and many of us can
in different ways uh identify with that
kind of struggle when life doesn't go
well it's exaggerated for cinematic
purposes but we all have some of that in
our real lives and then the multiverse
comes in in literally the way
that there's different versions of the
universe and all of them have a
different version of evelyn and the
gimmick which again i'm not spoiling
anything is that she learns how to
take advantage of skills that she or
versions of herself have picked up in
other versions of the universe and
there's sort of different parts of the
universe the multiverse are fighting
against each other and she has to do
battle and that's all i'm gonna tell you
about it but the great thing about this
particular version of the multiverse is
that it's not just oh look there's a lot
of weird things out there but it makes
us reflect on the real world
fact that there are roads not taken
right that there are things we could
have done decisions we could have made
where things would have turned out
differently we would have become
different people and so this is where
for me personally
the use of way out scientific
philosophical concepts is at its best in
telling the story making a movie
when it's making us think about the real
world okay it's not just amazing us with
how things would have been very
different if the world had been a
different kind of world it's making us
think about the world we actually live
in because we all have regrets or
wonder about how things could have been
different had we done things differently
so both daniels are uh really really
thoughtful people about everything from
the philosophy and science of the
multiverse to the techniques of writing
and making a movie uh the movie's been
getting rave reviews from people all
over it's not just for us multiverse
aficionados it's something for everyone
i encourage you to go see it and i think
you're going to like this conversation
because we get into a lot of things
that you don't normally get to talk
about with filmmakers so it's a
different perspective and i think that
it sort of resonated really really well
occasional reminders that we have a
webpage at
preposterousuniverse.compodcast with
show notes links full transcripts of
every episode completely searchable and
there's also a mindscape patreon page
you go to patreon.com
sean m carroll where you can support the
podcast get ad-free versions
suggest questions for the ask me
anything episodes and get a feeling of
belonging to a community of like-minded
mindscapers so again you can do that if
you want you don't have to it's great if
you're listening to minescape whatever
way it is tell your friends we want
everyone in the world listening to
mindscape everyone in the multiverse for
that matter even if i do not get
donations from elsewhere in the
multiverse at least i haven't figured
out a way to do that maybe i should
start thinking about that and with that
rather down to earth thought let's go
[Music]
daniel kwan and daniel scheinert welcome
to the mind skate podcast
hello good morning yes yeah
so you have a movie that's just come out
uh everything everywhere all at once and
there's a lot of things that happen but
let me just start with the obvious thing
that where you begin
is very mundane right i mean the
concerns of the movie right from the
start are uh food family
laundry taxes these are concerns that we
all have so i mean maybe this is just
storytelling 101 and it's obvious thing
to do but a little bit of insight into
why you chose to be quite that grounded
in things that we could all agree on
right from the start knowing that you're
gonna go some crazy places
yeah it's a great question i think a lot
of people um
expect multiverse movies to
exist in you know very high concept high
like superhero type genres and we wanted
to make sure that ours started in the
opposite just because we knew how wild
the rest of the film was going to be and
how
um how much we're going to ask the
audience to come along for this ride and
kind of suspend their disbelief and so
with this movie we were like let's let's
let's spend a decent amount of time at
the beginning just grounding
our characters in a very real world that
feels relatable and also as you know as
many people have been putting it mundane
um because in the end we knew we wanted
to find a lot of uh
small beautiful profound things in that
mundane um quality yeah we always knew
we wanted to juxtapose those things but
it did used to start we threw a lot of
things at the wall there used to be a
different opening scene where she was a
physics professor
doing like uh like michelle yo is
teaching the students about like the
waveform collapsing yeah yeah double
slit experiment yeah yeah i'm very sad
now you've made me sad that this is not
in the movie yeah there's a whole
deleted scene and then as she's showing
like the wave becomes particles she's
putting dots on the chalkboard uh and
then her clap her students start
giggling and she's like why are they
giggling she turns around and all the
dots have formed a perfect uh penis uh
and then she just and then she mutters
oh no she's here and then jobu walks in
and it was a whole matrix kind of
uh sci-fi intro but uh
but we kind of happened in class
yeah sorry one more time it's so
embarrassing when that happens in class
when you're lecturing on the double slit
experiment oh yes i'm sure yeah
oh is that common it's hard to bring the
classes attention back to the equations
once exactly exactly yeah well i mean
that's i mean that's kind of why i was
asking the question because you know
a superhero movie whatever people love
these obviously um
but it's not that we identify with the
characters it's that we aspire we wish
we could fly or be bulletproof or
whatever here it's much more like these
are our problems as well right
totally i mean i think some people
identify with
uh
megalomaniac white men um
and those people have had plenty of
movies you know about them you know like
most it's mostly about a guy who's like
got a good intentions but is a little
too egotistical
and we were like we'll make our
protagonist a little different a little
bit different are you just talking about
us now
that's what directors are for the most
part but that's what like the first
seven marvel movies were and it's so fun
that they're starting to change it up
but it was like it was like what's
thor's problem too confident what's
doctor strange's problem too confident
what's captain america's problem he's a
confident dude yeah
well i was you know look i love dr
strange and and my friend scott
derrickson who also was a previous
podcast guest directed doctor strange he
was my guy growing up in the comics but
but i always questioned this idea that
he was somehow uh made humble you know
he was arrogant and then he was humbled
like he became the sorcerer supreme
that's not exactly a humbling experience
that's kind of a fulfillment experience
totally yeah
but then okay you bring then things do
go crazy it's not mostly a movie about
uh paying your taxes on the laundromat
so there's a lot of places a lot of
movies you could make about paying your
taxes in the laundromat but you you
brought in the multiverse some crazy
ideas inspired by science fiction why is
that
a good place to go if you do want to
tell a more or less relatable story
yeah i mean um
our we kind of reverse engineered it and
we had this concept of a multiverse
story where you'd tap into lives you
could have led and and borrow their
skills
um and then we just started the two
sides of that coin that's really
interesting to us is first you get some
powers which is like great for you know
a crowd-pleasing action movie but then
on the flip side every time you tap into
a power the you know the double-edged
sword is you suddenly have an
existential crisis because you realize
you know how good your life could have
been right and that that felt like a
really fun um you know device to to
throw a character into yeah so then we
we talked about what character would be
the most interesting one to put through
the ringer and
uh
the more we talked the more we got
excited about being someone who's older
someone who's maybe our parents
generation who's had more life lived so
maybe more regrets uh and then we
started talking about our parents and
started talking about the immigrant
experience because dan's parents uh
immigrated and
and that was like even more interesting
like even more kind of color to like the
past lives the alternate lives they
could have led um
and uh
and then
and then yeah the the more mundane the
better where we were like oh if it's
someone who really doesn't feel good
about their life right now uh then this
journey is going to be
extra
you know existential for them
yeah um but ultimately extra rewarding
for them by the end right and then the
goal became you know to make a a big
flashy movie that ultimately is about
um how beautiful and wonderful
that normal life
was all along so you know we wanted to
make that
challenge which we knew early on was the
challenge um not too easy and be like no
no we're going to make you love the
taxes universe by the end you're going
to
you're going to be like i want to stay
right here in taxes you know my taxes
yeah get them right uh i mean i just
want to pause for a second to give kudos
to the amazing acting in the film
michelle yo uh most obviously she was
brilliant in this role thank you yeah i
mean uh we love taking credit um but we
don't deserve any credit she just killed
it she came
and was uh
so prepared and passionate and believed
in the movie um
yeah and i did i did find online that
there are a couple of interesting
alternate universes where different
people were playing the main character
in this movie right
yeah the the only two we ever tossed
around were very early on we were like
um
who are our favorite you know uh
chinese actors and we were like what if
we could get jackie chan or mich and or
michelle yo in our movie so early on
like you know
uh talking about them um and then when
we weren't sure about michelle yo our
producers were like who could you go to
you know if she's busy um
and we couldn't think of anyone because
we basically accidentally wrote
ourselves into a corner and like this
movie kind of lives or dies off of
michelle yo which was kind of a
terrifying terrifying realization
because we had been working on the movie
for a couple years at that point yeah um
but then almost as like a last-ditch
effort my my brain kind of went back and
then was like well you know in some ways
this character was inspired by my mom
maybe we could just cut the budget down
to like 10 of the original budget and
then the whole movie is like a prank
film where
these directors drag literally drag
their mom into their into their movie
and surround them with you know
uh
pedigreed actors and it would be more
like a jackass style uh like meta film
yeah
and nobody liked that idea we never
pitched it to his mom the producers were
like that's not that's not a real idea
don't well the reason i wanted to bring
this up because you know alternative
casting is always a weird thing we live
with what the world we got and it worked
out brilliantly and not only uh michelle
you but everyone in the movie is a
fantastic actor but
the movie is is like you just said it's
about thinking about all the roads not
taken right i mean that's why it's a
really to me a cool use of the
multiverse idea because it's not just
other worlds where weird things are
happening but other worlds where you
made different choices right it's very
very directly tied to
the real world the fact that we always
carry around with us these questions
about how things would have gone
differently had we done things a little
bit differently at crucial moments in
our past
totally
yeah i think i think a lot of people
keep asking us this question of why the
multiverse you know why is it happening
having a moment right now i think a lot
of people can relate to it because
there's never been a time where
our brains have been allowed to explore
all those paths you know all the
potential things that our lives could
have been and all the potential ways our
lives can still go um you know if i
wanted to i could you know pack my bags
and move to another city and have a
completely different life um and that
wasn't the case you know a hundred years
ago and i think or like what's extra
different is now you can go on google
maps you can go on zillow look at real
estate in any city in the world you can
go on instagram figure out what it would
be like to live
you know in any city figure out what all
your friends are doing there's even like
you know they talk about like dating app
tourism where you literally can just
change your um
location on your phone and suddenly you
can see who is single in malaysia or who
is single in brooklyn and and i know
some people who have actually done that
and then actually flew to that location
just to meet one person and so our
producer maybe did that
and that was beyonce
call him out on a podcast
um yeah and then now they're getting
gonna get married but he didn't go to
malaysia for like a mail or bride no no
no he went to new york where he had an
apartment
the whole idea is that i think this
movie is resonating with people and the
multiverse in particular is resonating
with people because we are living in the
existence that already feels like the
multiverse um and that's why we wrote
this movie that's a really cool point
because you know as a physicist i think
of the multiverse as being something
that we talk about is maybe
scientifically real in
a different sense than it would be in
this movie but i never thought about the
fact that in some sense we're closer to
the multiverse now in the modern world
because the space of possibilities for
our lives is bigger than if you grew up
you know as a peasant in the 14th
century or something like that
yeah it kind of goes back to um
i don't know if
you've read this or maybe you can even
prove me wrong if i if my research was
was um incorrect but when we were
reading about um everything about the
multiverse in preparation for writing
this movie one of the things i found
really interesting was one of the
earliest um recordings of the word
multiverse being used in the english
language actually had nothing to do with
science it had to do with uh morality
and and theology it was actually written
by a
theologist who was lamenting the fact
that um
he believed that there was one moral
unir universe like centered to
everything which was god um but then we
looked around at the secular world he he
was confused by the um
the
plurality of moralities and the the
moral multiverse that kind of made him
struggle every day and so that that was
where he that's where i mean
that's where
the word multiverse came from which is
really interesting because it's kind of
moved so far from there but like i feel
like that's where we live we're living
right now we're living in a place where
the internet has created so many moral
bubbles and different centers of
universes and what's happening now is
we're watching them collide and you know
we're all kind of terrified to see
what's going to happen next but to me
that i think that is real that like
that's one of the more interesting
things i came across while we were
reading
well and am i correct to well let me
just ask it as a question rather than
just saying statements
did scientific ideas or philosophical
ideas about the multiverse inspire you
at all or did you sort of hear them go
huh and just run with it yourself or did
you did you like i think you alluded to
reading about multiverse ideas
totally yeah no we yeah that was the
other thing i was just thinking is uh
yeah we're both um
really fascinated by science um but you
know we we only have enough uh
vocabulary to understand like pop
science books you know yeah we're really
big into like interdisciplinary studies
so like it's a it's about everything
combining yeah science is obviously a
big part of that and i always find like
i i just i love like a big
swing of a of a take on that on science
and philosophy or the state of the world
and
and uh when it makes me start feeling
emotional or kind of like sends me on a
philosophical tangent and and so reading
about like you know huge ideas of
physics like reading you know stephen
hawkings or reading like stuff about
evolution and like is is a huge source
of inspiration for us because we'll come
we'll come to each other and be like
whoa like what if okay like how did that
make you feel when you read that you
know article about the
uh what's it called the brain simulation
like what if it's more likely the
simulation argument brain would
would just form and
oh the bolt's been broken
right and we're like we'll come to each
other and be like what a crazy article
and it it's a and it and then we're kind
of off to the races kind of tossing
around how that could
you know affect a
a story you know and so for in this
particular case yeah we read a lot about
um multiverse
from every angle because i the fun thing
about the multiverse is almost every
single um
medium and every single field of study
has its own way into it um you know
because like there's the quantum
mechanics version of it which is all
about you know um probabilities and and
quantum decisions and things like that
uh but then if you go to cosmology that
we're talking about like the infinite
scale of of
of an expanding um universe that
contains a multiverse even within itself
um but the the way i got into it was
actually through linguistics oddly
enough i i came across this idea of
modal realism about 10 years ago um and
i was just so fascinated by this idea of
like taking the modality of language and
treating every version and every
variation as real as as almost as a
thought experiment um and just went down
a rabbit hole down that direction um but
you know mathematics has its own version
of the multiverse um i'd argue you know
joseph campbell talking about the many
faces of god is is another version of
just talking about infinity and again
talking about the multiverse and
and so like to me the entry point is
more like like we're saying it's more
interdisciplinary it's it's about this
this bigger picture um idea of us
looking at some at bigness at scale um
and trying to squeeze that into a sci-fi
action movie it was really fun
well i mean this is great because much
of what you just said i could easily
have said or have said before i've
written a lot about boltzmann brains and
about the quantum mechanical multiverse
the idea of modal realism is still one
that even i uh come up a little bit
short this is uh usually associated with
david lewis the famous philosopher who
yeah thinks that literally every
possible world is equally real and we
just happen to live in the one that we
find ourselves in and that that's i
think that's a step too far for me but
maybe i'm just you know too down to
earth i don't know
oh i mean totally i look to me the fun
thing about all this stuff is it it
reminds me like
obviously it's all rooted in some truth
but it still reminds me of the way that
um
you know our ancestors all interpreted
certain truths in different directions
like the way that they would you know
the ancient greeks would watch a
lightning strike and paint a picture of
a god um throwing lightning in anger or
whatever um or that the fact that you
know there was probably a great flood
you know thousands of years ago and
every single um civilization at the time
came up with their own version of a
story just describing that flood and
explaining that flood and i feel like
all these different things whether it's
modal realism or quantum mechanics or
whatever um we're all just pointing at
the same thing and we're trying to
understand it and so like i to me i i
believe none of it and i also believe
all of it it's a very strange thing
where it it it's the closest thing i
have to like a spirituality or to like
this idea of like a faith um because i i
will never be able to fully understand
any of it and so like you saying mobile
realism doesn't make sense it's like
totally fair
and to me it's just fascinating because
it's another tool for
pointing at the same thing sure yeah i
mean
i will make one point about quantum
mechanics which i tried because i know
that i have the my friends and audience
listeners out here who will care about
this which is just that you know i
really do believe that
in my body 5 000 times a second there is
a nuclear decay right there's a little
bit of radioactivity and there's the
universe in which that nucleus decayed
and one of which it didn't so i believe
there's many many many copies of me
being made all the time i actually do
believe this but i also don't i insist
that the versions of me
in the other universes are not me
they're like
they share a past with me but it's like
an identical twin you know like once we
split apart we're two different people
going our own ways we obviously have a
lot in common uh but it's not like
things that happen to that person affect
me in any way that's the one thing that
i want to make clear about my view of
the multiverse and it's perfectly i love
it if in the film
it is i feel like sometimes in
interviews people have like asked us
like what's interesting about the
multiverse and they're coming at it from
this like pop culture perspective uh
and i and i wish i was as articulate as
you because part of me wants to be like
well um
a lot of very smart people for very
valid reasons think it's real like it's
not
just a comic book thing guys like right
it's it's the best explanation we have
for
like these uh
you know
tiny uh physics observations and like uh
but then it goes both ways there's a
very good chance and there's an infinite
number of us and we are in a we are
living the life of a random
one one of them yeah and that's
mind-blowing to me and like that was a
huge inspiration for this movie to just
be like
i don't know how that makes me feel and
i don't know what to do about it
but i kind of am excited to stare at it
for a few years and and see if i can
tell a story
through that like
mind like that just absurd
but maybe real
premise you know which is why you know
we push for those who have seen it you
know you you know we push our character
to
the you know cognitive limits and in our
audience as well because we're trying to
basically touch upon what it really
feels like when we when we
treat that as real whatever you just
said the this refreshing of our bodies
like how um
how terrifying how beautiful
yeah but kind of how beautiful it's like
oh well my
it's a miracle that i'm like uh
able to reach over and pick up this
object right now like
and observe just one
you know ending
and you know as you as you alluded to
before uh in all this infinity of
possible
futures that my past self had the one
that you're focusing on in the movie
from chelsea's character is the one in
which she's the worst she came out the
worst of all of that yeah and it's still
not so bad so i mean that's a little bit
of hopefulness in there right totally
yeah and it's almost and that's almost
from a a place of judgment from the
alpha universe which is sort of
you know the there's so if there are
villains in this movie it's probably
them um and so even though they say that
i don't think we actually believe it and
i don't think um
i don't think by the end the character
doesn't believe it obviously but in that
moment is the worst thing that she can
hear and um she takes it to heart
because i think uh
um a lot of people feel that way you
know i think a lot of people no matter
who you are or where you are in the
world they have this feeling that maybe
maybe this is the worst version of me
how did i how did i screw up so many
things to get to this point and so to i
think a lot of people like
laugh at that moment in the in the movie
when the character says that but then
i've also heard people say that this
actually made them tear up because they
felt so uh targeted almost it's like you
know the the
film was was speaking to them and i love
that because i think if it was speaking
to them in that moment then i think by
the end of them hopefully it really
pulls them out of that and and makes
them believe in the pos the future
possibilities if you know if we are
constantly fracturing out into you know
infinite number of versions of ourselves
every
few milliseconds like you're saying that
also means we are getting resets every
every moment every moment is a new uh
possibility that um we get to choose
which is really i don't know it's really
thrilling to think about let me push on
that a little bit this is a totally
unfair set of questions to ask but one
pushback i get when i talk about the
quantum mechanical universe is that it
makes life meaningless if everything
happens then who cares about what
choices i make because there's some
other universe in which i made other
choices i try to argue that you know not
all universes are created equal this is
a feature of the quantum version of
things where there's sort of more of you
in some
versions of the universe than there are
in other ones but of course you get to
cheat in the movie because you get to
access all the universes at once but
what is your stance toward this sort of
meaningfulness if all these infinite
number of things are happening
yeah i mean i think that we
we went into the project unsure what our
stance was and and that was a lot of
times that's what attracts us to a
project is like
uh
is that oh we're gonna
we're gonna chew on a big scary question
for a while um
and because because you're right like
well the multiverse is actually kind of
anti-narrative in that way where if you
have a character make a decision and you
know in the back your head that the
other decision was also um just as valid
and just as just as realized then
nothing matters because in narrative the
character is only built off of their
decisions which like yeah which then in
real life is like yes so disempowering
or can be so disempowering so we asked
ourselves can we make a multiverse movie
where we lean into that and say i'm
gonna make you not care i'm gonna make
the
character not care i'm gonna make the
audience not care and
basically stare at the meaninglessness
of all their decisions um and see if we
could pull ourselves out of that because
we don't believe that i think we needed
to convince ourselves that even if we
are just one tiny speck
in in a sea of infinite other versions
of ourselves that there's something
still worth holding on to in this moment
uh so yeah the answer we stumbled upon
so we figured it out
is that um
[Music]
podcast
uh i mean or the answer that we we used
to get ourselves out of this impossible
project and so we could actually release
it uh was um
that like too much nihilism is a bad
thing
uh
but a little bit's not so bad and and
and that like a lot of people
are so convinced they're right you know
kind of like evelyn our main character
that they that they're making themselves
miserable they're they're making the
world around them you know
maybe not a better place and that like
there's something kind of freeing about
about that scary concept of you know
um
this universe is a random one um
and and
and we kind of feel like that most
people if if if they took a step back
and stared at that scary question and
then they ask themselves do i want to be
a nice person or a mean person
the answer just intuitively is like
a nice one like
i guess i want to do good in the world i
guess i want to spend time with the
people i love like maybe i'll quit like
uh
screaming online at people i hate
uh
and
and bake some cookies for my neighbor if
uh if i have a little existential crisis
a little healthy one yeah i i don't know
how deep we want to go down like the the
road of like morality or just like
turning this into a morale detail but um
you know because i i was raised very
religious you know evangelical almost
fundamentalist christian and um
and so now i'm very allergic to like uh
objective morality or any any kind of
any way of talking about um those kind
of things in an objective sense is very
um scary to me but um i am fascinated
about the fact that like
um
for so long the golden rule was sort of
like this very strong center to to
humanity the idea of like treat your
neighbor as you would like to be treated
it has been such a big um
big part of of human morality you know
and uh i'm we're watching that break
down um and i think a big reason why is
because
the definition of neighbor has just been
stretched thin
i think that was really useful back when
we had communities of you know a few
hundred people even a few thousand
people um but now when the community and
the neighbors are literally
in the billions like there's there's no
way for that
rule to actually holds true anymore and
so like
to me what you know what china's talking
about about nihilism allowing us to say
nothing matters throw out everything for
a moment just give it hit the reset
button so we can take a step back and
find a new center or new um a new
yeah a new version of morality because
because you know i think we constantly
have to be updating those kinds of
things as the world changes
and i think what we discovered on this
movie and is being echoed in a lot of
art that's being made right now it's not
just not just our film um is this idea
it's like
the neighbor concept is i think is is is
is failing us and so we have to just
look at it instead of saying how do we
want to treat other people it's it's
it's it's more about the freedom that we
need to be giving everyone and so i
think this new the new the new morality
that i'm chasing is this idea of nothing
matters there are no rules let everyone
do whatever they want as long as you're
kind as long as it's not hurting anyone
why does it matter and i feel like that
you know those things will be up to
debate forever like who is who is every
action hurting and to what degree and
and and and um we will always be
struggling with that but rather than
being trapped in this idea of of trying
to police our neighbors or think of just
the individual neighbor
um i like the idea of just freeing us
ourselves up to say
don't worry about it nothing matters
just be kind
i promise we'll get in a minute to like
down-to-earth questions about
screenwriting and movie-making but i
have some still some deep questions deep
issues i want to talk about because this
is our jam no we're excited
about me i'm just going to chime in and
say i still think treating your neighbor
how you want to be treated checks out
for me i don't know you know it's like
no it checks out but it's limited now i
think i think it's it's breaking down he
treats his neighbors like garbage i just
i never want to be like damn maybe he
wants like to be treated like that maybe
he wants to be treated like that he's
growing dog [ __ ] over
yeah i just want to be yeah i just want
to be ashamed and
right
well the flip side of this is when you
contemplate these gigantic multiverses
not only do you think about you know
does it is it meaningful because i could
have done other things the other
worry from the existentialist side of
things is i noticed that i am very small
inside this huge collection of
infinitely many things happening even if
it's not other me's out there there's
certainly a lot of other stuff out there
so i personally kind of when people
bring that up i kind of lean on a
version of the serenity prayer i'm like
well yeah but know the wisdom to
understand what you can affect what you
can't and even if it's small then that
is what matters to you right
yeah that's um that's great because what
what you just said is kind of where my
brain has been at the past couple weeks
the the serenity prayer just like
knowing when in the limits of of the
individual
um
and uh that's probably going to go into
our next movie i don't know
there's something there that is really
profound and my
our via our visual effects supervisor
who's a good friend of ours who worked
on the movie he this morning he
literally just sent me a podcast about
that very thing about the the limits the
you know the the limitless expectations
and limitless imagination that we have
um versus the limited bodies that we can
that contain them you know and like that
that tension is so um awful right
and then i feel like on the other side
is like uh
i've recently been like reading more
like alan watts uh
like
philosophizing i haven't read much but
like
there's something so it's one of the
only philosophers i've read where i'm
like oh this kind of just adds up it's
all just like
there's it's not like super
difficult to parse out i mean i guess
that's what he's known for is being like
hey i'm gonna take eastern philosophy
and make it so
uh westerners can understand it but
like his
you know he talks about like how it can
be a
a really upsetting dangerously upsetting
thing to really focus on the self
as something 100 separate from the rest
of the world and that like
and that it's a poorest thing you know
like there's your consciousness is that
the self or there's your body is that
the self like uh
but the food in your stomach is not the
self or maybe but like maybe it's just
this becoming the self but maybe it's
this like
thing that like you control some but
like you control it less and less the
further goes out but also like
dan is a part of me like my community is
a part of me and like um
the universe as huge as it is is me um
and that there's something kind of like
beautiful about that where it makes you
feel less shitty about being so tiny
um
and then you're like
i love redwood trees good thing those
are
part of me yeah because i'm part of
earth pretty cool i think it's a high
five to redwood tree and be like i look
good
this is a good that's my version of
allen watson
but the and the great thing about art in
general is it can take these
lofty ideas from science or philosophy
or whatever and bring them down like
once you have to
make it manifest in the plot and
characters of the story then that's sort
of what matters like philosophers love
them i'm kind of one myself but you can
talk in abstractions all the time and it
can often be like an extra step that
doesn't get taken to make that real in
people's lives but as filmmakers you
have no choice
you're showing people doing things on
the screen yeah i think it's i think
sometimes we come into a project with
like
with some hot takes that we're real
confident about you know um and then
when you start having to like illustrate
them with human beings and try to make
them relatable it's like humbling and
you're like oh there's more nuance to
this like the point i was trying to make
is changing because uh
because i want it to feel real and real
people aren't as black and white as you
know
my opinion you know like a bumper
sticker is easier and then like so even
while working on this project you know
like i think we
we
had to put our shoes put put ourselves
in the shoes of these characters that
are our parents generation
and like
i think at first we were a little like
know-it-ally
as we did that and we were like
yeah and and through the process of
making it we're like it's not easy
right to like understand your children
who were raised on the internet if you
weren't raised on the internet it's not
easy
to like
you know understand your kids pronouns
when your kids pronouns change like
that's
hard yeah and
but it's also still important um but but
anyway yeah that's what your comment
kind of made me think about is like art
bad art is like just propaganda where
someone's screaming a hot take but i
think like
yeah the the good art which we aspire to
make you know requires nuance and you're
like oh whoa i'm having to get in the
weeds here
well you're giving me an idea that maybe
it should be required in philosophy
courses that all the students write a
little bit of a screenplay to illustrate
the ideas that they're that they're
thinking about like really put it into
action somehow
i think it's a great idea that's amazing
and vice versa i think like filmmakers
should have to take a philosophy course
and figure out what on earth they're
trying to say otherwise they'll just go
out and just like have someone shoot a
bunch of people in the forehead because
it looks cool and they never think about
what it means or why they made that
movie you know right
all of this is reminding me of a
of something i read once and i'm going
to attribute it to kurt vonnegut but
that might be totally wrong but uh when
in doubt when in doubt
yeah but um basically it helped me
understand our place in in the world as
storytellers um and basically the idea
is uh in order for any paradigm shift to
happen and for any any big idea to come
into the the zeitgeist um you need three
types of people um the first one are the
um
the
the ones who basically come up with the
idea and are treated like um like
heretics or just like crazy people
insane people they're the ones who have
an idea so wild that the world rejects
it um
then the second person you need is
someone who basically looks at that
crazy person and says the first one who
says
oh wait there's something here this
person actually um is on to something
and they're the ones who validate it
they're the ones who's who bring them
into um
into like out out from the outskirts and
into society the podcasters exactly the
podcast exactly yes exactly
the final the final person that is
needed is the storyteller it's the
person who can take these very
complicated um
just they are convoluted complicated
contradictory ideas um that the the
world is not ready for and turning it
into something digestible um and
something scalable for for society and
so after i after i heard that i was like
okay
i can do that that sounds that sounds
like something worth worthy of my time i
want to chase after complicated feelings
and complicated ideas and try to turn
them into something that my mom can
understand or you know you know high
school kids can understand or at least
begin to understand and so i i do think
whether it's
for science or philosophy or any of
these fields that the person who um
translates to the masses is such an
important part of all of this and i
think i think a lot of storytellers
forget that that is one of the many hats
we can wear
[Music]
yeah there's plenty of movies out there
with the shooting in the head we look
but uh i like the idea that a little bit
of
forced reflection
yeah might make them into slightly
better i mean
it makes me think about like uh
on the other side of on the less
optimistic side uh dan was i haven't
read this but you were telling me about
i think socrates like was really
anti-playwrights and like
anti-storytellers oh maybe
it might have been plato but like one of
them was like
uh there's nothing factually
reliable about
a piece of theater it's just emotionally
effective and then
he's like if you're trying to create
like an educated populist who's trying
to figure out how the world really works
the worst thing you can do is just throw
art at them that's super persuasive and
has no scientific method involved at all
you know and i
and i love sometimes
you know it's like such a fun humbling
thought to be like i'm yeah
sometimes i'm trans i could be
translating something important for the
masses and other times i could just be
throwing misinformation
out there that's as hot that's as
detrimental as something the kremlin you
know uh is cooking up or you know
there's a responsibility there yeah one
of my recent guests peter dodds is a
statistician data scientist
but he studies uh that you know
uses big data to study stories and
narrative and his motto is never bring
statistics to a story fight it's just
not going to
be a
fair fight the stories are always going
to win
uh that's such a bummer yeah because
yeah i think about that a lot
uh
because we
we started off like uh we've been
thinking about it a lot in the last few
years that like our work early on was
just us uh dancing with the algorithm
like
you know what kind of short film can i
make that you know youtube will um like
um and we weren't spending much time
thinking about like uh
you know what the difference that might
make in the world you know yeah um
and uh and then sometimes you look back
and you're like oh i
accidentally
spread misinformation you know like even
if it's just representation in media uh
you know you can do the statistics
you're like 20 of people look like this
but
uh 100 of people in this movie
look like this uh but also like
um
you know like our obsession with serial
killer
stories makes us think there's more
serial killers than ever
when homicides are way down or that
there's child predators everywhere but
it's way down
it's like oh that's not
yeah
i love statistics and sometimes i
have so much guilt about being a
filmmaker
well you know as a scientist as a
physicist who lives in los angeles i've
consulted on a bunch of films including
a bunch of marvel films and uh
you know i'm very much of the opinion
that
i i'm not going to object to
the laws of physics being broken in the
movie like what is the point of that uh
but but there's still a little voice
inside of me that sometimes
squeals or gets annoyed or something
like that so i'm only gonna do one
little i'm gonna let you know i'm gonna
let you in on the one part of a kind not
just your movie but movies like this
that i can't quite stop thinking about
just to get your reaction to it which is
just the fact that infinity
is very big
when you talk about an infinite number
of things that can happen
most of them are either terrible or
boring right i mean the vast majority of
universes out there don't have us in
them at all not just like other versions
of us and and oftentimes when people
portray like douglas adams and the
hitchhiker's guide right the in
infinite improbability drive
they portray other possibilities as kind
of cute and fun and there's there's an
example in your movie where you do this
also and so i mean how i mean is it just
forget about that we're telling the
story we're going to have fun we're
going to be cute or do you contemplate
the idea that you know in the vastness
of infinity most of it is terrible and
boring
yeah no that's that's my pet peeve too
and it was kind of uh
yeah hard to grapple with um
and we we threw a lot at the wall we nod
to that a bit you know there's a there's
a universe where um life doesn't um and
the conditions weren't right to form or
whatever and that most of them are like
this but then it turns out that universe
they're still talking yeah you still
made it cute it was still cute it was my
favorite part of the movie but it was
still adorable oh great thank you
um
but yeah i mean you're right there is
that that tension between uh what is
accurate and what is going to help the
story and i think for the most part the
universes that we picked were the ones
that would collide with the um
with the protagonist the best and so um
a lot of it ended up being the the
wilder ones which is kind of interesting
and we kind of yeah maybe maybe we'll do
a sequel that's like all boring
universes it's just universes that are
just like so mundane and nothing's
happening yeah yes nothing's happening
forever gets the title that's the stupid
score i think it'd be great
[Laughter]
um but yeah i mean we wanted
to
start with something extra
accessible and cute and be like oh what
if there was one other universe and
and like from very early on we were like
we're going to introduce more and more
the audience is going to get a little
stressed out and then we're going to
pull the rug out and we're going to
introduce
a stupid number
of universes to kind of
point at infinity almost like an
exponential curve of universes you know
for a movie um
knowing like there was no logical way we
could film
you know like there would be limitations
of what we could film and also what
would be you know
interesting at all to look at but
hopefully
hopefully people leave our movie and
they
they can tell that we
were pointing at even more universes
than what we showed like uh and that
like
ours is a cute little
is like a cute version of the physics
because
and and we yeah i'd love nothing more if
people
took that germ of a feeling and went off
and actually
did some research read into it more you
know because it's it's fascinating yeah
well this brings up a filmmaking point
because
once you've granted yourself access to
the multiverse
you can be as silly as you want uh as
weird and bizarre and shocking as you
want and and i don't wanna put words in
your mouth but i get the feeling that
you enjoy that that that freedom i mean
how much do you have to pull back and
say no no no that's just too silly or
too gross or too off-putting versus yes
let's let's you know shock the audience
just a little bit
totally yeah it's a constant debate
within ourselves i think we're always
trying to surprise ourselves because if
we surprise ourselves and we surprise
the audience and like what better gift
to give an audience and we get bored
easily so we try to make a movie that
would not bore us uh but then we're
always you know with every new
ingredient we add we're always doing the
calculation in our head of like okay
what percentage of the audience are we
going to lose if we include this this
element that's too far and like how
important is it to the
the main character's journey and and
that kind of became the the back and
forth yeah but the most shocking thing
about all of this is you know we're used
to our movies
cutting out a certain you know pushing
away certain audience members because
it's too much it's too weird it's too
you know aggressively strange
and um
that's why we're always doing these
calculations in our heads and so we
expected certain people to
you know walk out of this movie being
like that was not for me um but uh i
think something has happened in the time
um
since we started making this movie where
the world has just gotten so weird and
the world has gotten so chaotic you know
you read headlines and they feel like a
parody uh website is writing these
headlines but they're real you know
these these are actually happening real
life feels absurd
um and for some reason you know
audiences are really embracing this
movie way more than we ever expected um
the fact that we're even on this podcast
right now is very funny to me because
this is not what we were
imagining when we set out to write this
movie we thought we would find some
interesting weirdos like us who would
enjoy this and that would be that and
and we would be happy with that but this
is kind of proof that something has
shifted and and the world is ready for
um
art that reflects life and right now
life is absurd that was i mean that
ended up being our excuse for keeping a
lot of the
most shocking stuff in there was uh that
the internet is shocking and that like
in a lot of ways this movie's in
conversation with how it feels to
to to live online these days and and
even our parents generation is spending
more time online than ever and is more
aware than ever of just how like
you can scroll between something that
makes you like
smile to something that disturbs you
so quick and and we wanted to not
uh we want to do that justice a little
and be like you know our generation grew
up on the internet like that there's
sexual content
around every corner on you know and so
like we're like there should be
cuss words and sex toys in our movie
even though that's going to make our you
know moms disappointed with how you know
where our film school tuition went
uh
but it felt you know yeah authentic
i mean it's another funny sorry i
haven't really thought about this uh
enough i guess but just the fact that
not only do we have this technology now
and it's changed our lives in certain
ways but one of the ways is
the
whiplash the rapidity with which we can
be pushed from one thing to another like
i i don't know about you i grew up with
10 channels on the tv and you know some
books that you know in
any one book for a long time but with
thousands of channels on tv and
literally millions billions probably of
websites out there you can get this sort
of
conceptual emotional um
feeling of of just being just chaos at a
very very rapid rate and i guess that is
partly what has been reflected in the
film
yeah it's wild like i mean i think
people have always loved camping because
you kind of
calm down but
you know i you know i'm not that old so
i can't speak for what camping was like
in the 80s but i feel like when i when i
go somewhere and my phone doesn't work
for two days like
it is wild how different i feel and how
my brain feels and it's like it's like
only when you get off the drugs do you
realize just how
bad it was different life feels when you
don't take your drugs
but it's like that but yeah the movie i
think the people who really click with
this movie are the ones who immediately
understand that the whiplash that you're
feeling is intentional you know i think
some people watch it they they aren't
ready to let go and it's it's it's a lot
it's it's it's almost abusive to the
audience this movie sometimes of course
we we took
a lot of care in making sure that the
abuse was rewarded but um
once you let go and realize the whiplash
is intentional you are ready for this
roller coaster ride and we use a lot of
genre and we use a lot of like really
quick snappy um
filmmaking techniques to make it
apparent um but it is fun to to be
sitting in an audience with a bunch of
people and some people are laughing and
some people are crying and some people
are screaming all at the same time
watching the same exact scene but
reacting in all these different ways um
because that's that's what it feels like
on the internet when someone posts like
a tragedy online that's what it's like
some people are cheering some people are
crying some people are
making jokes it's it's a very strange
way to exist where you're not allowed to
have your own feelings about something
anymore because the world is having it
first
let me just take advantage of having you
here because you talked about uh your
goals with a movie like this how does it
come together is it always the same or
is this is every movie different i mean
you start with the characters the the
plot device uh the images
yeah i think um
we start with um
like throwing a lot up in the air you
know like even right now as we try to
figure out what our next movie um
might be
we have
too many ideas and too many like things
about the world that are interesting us
and we're kind of always just waiting
for
a bunch of our favorite ones to coalesce
you know and it's kind of like this like
aha moment that's not just one idea it's
it's that moment where like
oh that project will let me do
10 of the things that that interest me
right now
um i'm not going to get bored with that
uh
which is the other half of my answer
which is like
we like to do things that um
won't we won't be sure if it worked and
we won't be done until the very end you
know like
this was like a it took us all the way
through mixing the movie
you know to refine the
what we were saying and and uh we're
constantly tweaking things because we
pick because we bit off something right
hard um
yeah one one thing i'll say is i think
we write the wrong way you know i think
classically you're supposed to um
this is actually a metaphor that our
composers used for their process and i'm
stealing it now so sun lux they were the
band that composed the score for this
film and they described their process
like this they say normally an architect
will build a house and you get the
structure right you make sure everything
feels safe and sound and then you go
inside and you start to populate the
house with furniture and you know
appliances and things that make sense um
but their process which feels very
similar to ours is instead of building
the house first they might like be
walking down the street and come across
this amazing chair this amazing armchair
with like 10 legs and it has leather but
also you know there's some some pokey
parts you know that stick out if you
don't sit in the right but they love it
and say this chair is incredible i'm
going to build a whole house around this
chair and i'm going to make this chair
make sense this chair doesn't make sense
right now it doesn't make sense in my
mom's house but i'm going to build a
house where this chair makes perfect
sense and to me i'm like when i heard
them describe that i was like yes that's
exactly how we work we find these weird
chairs and when we spend the rest of our
time
just trying to build a house around it
and i think for for this movie you know
the chaos was the chair infinity was the
chair like i want to build an entire
thing around infinity
even if it structurally doesn't make
sense or structurally doesn't follow the
rules this is going to be a very hard
challenge but a very fulfilling one if
we pull it off
i wish i'd done that with my actual
house i just did renovations and
and my favorite sofa didn't fit in it
and i had to get rid of it yeah defeat
the purpose of a house if your favorite
sofa does not yeah really yeah it just
didn't make sense in the room well i
mean maybe this is something worth
explaining to people who don't make
movies for livings i think that a lot of
people
presume that you have a script and then
you film it but there's still a lot of
picking and choosing along the way right
you film things that don't make it into
a movie you end up filming things that
maybe weren't in the script i mean how
what is the planning versus chaos
element uh in that process um
totally yeah i think i think there are
filmmakers like the kind of classic
hitchcock
uh style is that like he would
perfect his script perfect his shot list
have storyboards and he'd come in and
he'd move around his actors like chess
pieces and execute exactly what he had
planned all along uh but that's
so hard
like with live action and and also kind
of like very unpleasant and like the
opposite of why i got into filmmaking
you know i like the collaboration and
the problem solving uh and the fact that
you're
learning new things all along it's also
it's a self-limiting you know if if
you're going to go in there and say i
know exactly what i want you there's no
room for the universe to tell you better
things you know or to show you better
ways of making the film that you're
making and i think i think a film like
this
would never have worked if we had gone
the hitchcock route i think we had to be
constantly listening constantly feeling
out what our crew members were saying
and and what the locations were telling
us and how you know just everything down
to like you know scheduling around
different actors schedules like all that
is speaking to you and you you have to
listen as a filmmaker because otherwise
you're just fighting against entropy and
you're fighting against um
just
inertia which is like impossible
yeah it's like so
for example we get
we get all the way into like the final
weeks of um the edit
and there's still things that some
audiences aren't latching onto about
um
the logic of the movie and we started we
were still rewriting lines of dialogue
to try to and just in just one line of
dialogue could make such a difference
that would then help everyone just help
a few more people give up uh and uh
to the absurdity of the bagel for
example um and we were tweaking those
lines straight up to the end or like
there was one shot that we added to the
opening of the film that's just the
daughter
sad driving her car and like the
simplest shot but it wasn't in the
script it wasn't in the edit
and and something about the daughter's
journey
felt like it wasn't set up properly and
audiences were like why is it all about
the daughter at the end and so like
we i think it's a a product of how much
we're trying to squeeze into our movie
and how ambitious our ideas are but like
you we were we added that really late
and it made a huge difference you know
um it's a chemistry set yeah and just
gotta keep tweaking those those
the the proportions until like it feels
right um but yeah to answer your
question
in another way he's he comes from improv
i come from animation it's um animation
is filmmaking when you have all the
control and improv comes from all um
filmmaking where you have no control and
i think our our style of and our process
is somewhere in the middle where we plan
as much as we possibly can but knowing
that our projects are so ambitious we
have to leave a lot of room for improv
and also knowing that we have
really talented friends and we want to
leave room for their ideas uh
you know
leave room for the actors to come in and
surprise us
well one of the features of the film is
these wonderful um
hong kong cinema fight scenes right
and presumably those are pretty darn
choreographed but i mean how much were
you just nodding toward that sort of
genre of film versus actually using the
techniques that they would use to make a
fight scene like that
yeah
growing up that was like all we watched
in the house because my dad loved
watching movies and my mom
fell asleep in most movies unless they
were in chinese and so my dad would just
constantly be finding like bootleg
copies of um you know hong kong action
movies and things like that so we
watched a lot of that growing up and
both of us you know we both connected
over the fact that we loved that kind of
um filmmaking style and what was great
about it for this movie is not only is
it so
damn surely and um
satisfying and it's our favorite but it
also happens to be uh
not that expensive compared to um
the kind of like
bombast of like american action he's
like it's all about like two people
fighting over a prop uh as opposed to
you know 100 people with guns as the
building falls it doesn't make it easier
in fact i think it's much harder to pull
off hong kong action because it requires
um
every performer to be incredibly
physically able and then also the camera
work has to be very precise and you have
to have a team who's all dedicated to
this idea of shooting
action kind of unconventionally you know
i think a lot of
um
things have been changing in american
action films but for a very long time
the way that we shot action was the same
way that we'd shoot coverage of like any
other dialogue scene where you you get
the wide shot of the whole thing then
you get some close-ups and then if you
need some inserts for clarity you go and
get like this foot kicking this thing um
which is like way more efficient because
then you're not changing light setups
constantly you're not you're not turning
around and forcing the whole crew to
move every single time you do another
take but that ends up you know when you
cut it together there's a dryness to it
that feels like you're shooting it as if
it's a conversation um and not like a
dance not like a proper fight and the
way that um in hong kong um yunu ping
was the the you know legendary
choreographer that did almost all of
that stuff or at least influenced a lot
of that stuff and that his way of
shooting would be he would just choose
the exact shot for every single move
that would best uh illustrate um
the feeling and also narratively the
story
um in that moment so even if it was just
one punch to a face he would find the
perfect shot for it and hit that punch
and then cut to a wide and suddenly the
fall would have a very specific angle
that would make the fall feel very
dramatic and so even if
um sometimes it cuts fast it's always
very narrative narratively clear
and there's also you know these
incredible moments where
they just let the performers perform
because they're that good you can just
hold on a stationary tripod shot for
a decent amount of time and just be
impressed by um how incredible these uh
athletes are
and then the the last thing in our hong
kong spiel we like to say is that uh
uh we we referenced it so heavily tried
so hard to make something that could
stand up to like michelle yo's career
yeah um
uh and then we tried to not hurt anyone
yeah and so the difference was when we
did our action scenes we had very thick
wires and we just removed them in post
but like classic hong kong action movies
they used thin wires that the camera
couldn't see and it's so dangerous and
like a lot of people got hurt and a lot
of people would get hurt on those movies
and so we're we're happy we found a
a safe way you know to do that style um
because uh we did not want
to hurt michelle yo our hero
and that's compatible with the
underlying lesson of the movie i guess
which which maybe makes this a good last
question to ask
is there a lesson to the movie is there
moral to the story and and should movies
have morals or is it just
not i shouldn't say just but is the goal
more to
give people a bunch of ideas to think
about and come up with their own stories
i mean how pat should the lesson be at
the end versus a little bit of loose
thread chaos left hanging there
totally yeah i think it's all we're
always searching for a balance in there
and i'm not sure what the right
vocabulary words are but like
uh
you know we have
we have a very concise moral to the
story that's so uh
um
simple it sounds like a children's book
you know which is like
uh it's chaos be kind um
but
on top of that we tried to make every
character's journey
nuanced and explore things that didn't
have super black and white answers and
and leave room for everyone to kind of
see what resonates with them when they
leave the theater and not
end the movie with someone
walking off into the sunset happily ever
after so that like hopefully there's
uh
things to chew on that are gray and
and that you know
it's it does feel like the movie's out
of our hands now and we read think
pieces online and we're like whoa i
guess the movie means that like
cool
which is such a fun experience i think
that's all a product of the fact that
like um we don't go into every movie
with the moral we don't know what the
moral is going to be you know if there
is going to be one at all and um hoping
you know we just kind of enter every
project hoping that we will find
something that we can learn um and if
we're learning again if we're learning
then the audience is learning and that's
that's exciting to us and so um i think
that's probably why you know people have
a hard time pinning down what this film
means is because it
it it grew into its meaning rather than
us placing some like some seed of
meaning at the beginning um which i
think is like in my
you know
my experience those are my favorite
kinds of films is where it feels like
the filmmaker is searching the
filmmakers is looking for something
rather than trying to teach something i
i like reflecting back on a lot of our
work i feel like a lot of oftentimes
uh
the characters are um
all the worst aspects of our characters
are the worst aspects of ourselves as
writers and as humans um and we're
putting putting those people into these
movies so that we can hopefully see
um a way to become a better person
through the process um it's and that's i
think hopefully that's something that
people feel
it's like a hybrid our filmmaking
process is a hybrid of jackass and
therapy yeah
we're like we just want to do things
that are fun to do and fun to watch
uh
and we also want to like try to grow as
people along the way and maybe that'll
be valuable for the audience too well
and and evelyn has triumphed but next
year she's still going to have to pay
her taxes again right i mean there's no
escape from this yeah exactly it's still
chaos yeah she doesn't you know still
chaos that is a great that's the moral
it's still chaos so be kind to each
other so daniel and daniel scheiner
thanks so much for being on the mineski
podcast
such a pleasure yes wow this is
hoping to say anything too stupid next
time we're gonna interview you i still
have i know we have more questions for
you yeah i have answers some of them
will be crazy some of them will be wrong
but i'll give them oh great maybe maybe
we should consult or ask you to consult
on our next movie obviously now that now
that we've connected this is very
exciting you know how to get me yeah
love it all right thanks very much guys
cheers nice to meet you
[Music]
you